he just said that she was going to go  out there and she that is why Pearl asks  you doesn't that selfish or why are you  going out there and deliberately  deciding to have a child as a single  parent what would you like that I'd  rather you shut your legs I don't have  no children if you can't be in a healthy  relationship will a man and woman  together getting on well to raise a  child together and you're deliberately  going out there and choosing to have a  child as a single parent shut your  exercise  what I said is I would rather have a  child with two parents in separate homes  than to have them under one home in a  toxic situation  you said but I'm saying you didn't even  try to have the relationship with the  friend because I don't know  whole point